You are now going to be You are now
going to be sued.
You are now going to be sued for saying
I paid A MILLION DOLLARS. YOU'RE GOING
TO BE SUED. Love how he's uh panicking.
Well, it's very surprising because
telling me about his sex life didn't
help him. Telling me that he worked for
the Mossad would have given him a get
out of jail free card. Remember, One
sec. One sec. One sec. One sec. One sec.
Did you guys just hear that?
Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when his soul is taken away, Allah says
he's going to say, "What? Send me back
to do Hajj, Umrah, Salah, fasting? What?
No. Sadaqah." Brothers and sisters, Iera
is getting thousands of shahadas
monthly, yearly. Hundreds of thousands
of people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training dawah. Brothers and sisters, do
you want a part of that sadaqah jariyah
that goes on forever? This is how Islam
has spread around the world, brothers
and sisters. Carry on this legacy of the
process of Islam, inshallah, by donating
whatever amount, inshallah, and support
Iera right now, inshallah. Enjoy the
video. As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi
wa barakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. Hope you guys are well,
inshallah. So, we're going to get
straight into this, inshallah. This is
going to be
It just gets better. Every time with
Zionism and Israel, it just gets better.
It just gets better. And I mean, it's
just free subscription. You don't even
need to pay for it. They just see it
yourself. Here is
Piers Morgan invited by Bassem Youssef
and Dershowitz, the the the lawyer
that's representing a a P, the maybe the
biggest P in in history, with an island
to blackmail the elites, etc., to use
them, you know, sponsored by Mossad,
sponsored by IDF, the one that, you
know, promoted by Tommy Robinson. So,
here's
how it goes, inshallah. And it gets
Oh boy, you guys are not ready for
what's about to come. Let's get straight
into it, inshallah.
You've studied these files in a lot more
detail than most. What is your
assessment of that?
It's It's not It's not a simple
question. It doesn't have a simple
answer. What I first tell people is just
Google or or use a search engine that
functions, Draw Site News, Epstein,
Israel, and you'll find a series of
stories that we have published already
and that we're consistently adding to.
But then you can also ask yourself just
some basic questions. All right, how did
he get an Austrian fake passport? I mean
a real passport with a fake name in
1982. Like that's There aren't There
aren't many regular people that can get,
you know, fake passports to help them
travel around the world. Another
important thing to understand is that,
you know, three of the people that he is
very closely associated with in the
1980s are uh Stan Pottinger, who is a,
you know, attorney who's known to have
moved money for the CIA during
Iran-Contra, uh Adnan Khashoggi, who was
like the banker during Iran-Contra
moving money and weapons to Saudi.
Listen, why is this guy going into so
much detail? This is a simple uh
question and a simple answer. Was he an
asset of Mossad and Israel? Yes, he was.
I mean, you've got Tommy Robinson trying
to make Epstein a Muslim because he was
apparently sent the sent this kisswa,
apparently it's fake, or he was wearing
a shemagh, and he's definitely a Muslim.
The guy just had two items on or uh on
his position, he's a Muslim. But then
all of this trail of his connections to
Mossad and uh Israel, uh uh
uh it's not an easy answer. Of course,
it is. Come on, my friend. Do you Come
on, what's going on here? Come on. Let's
go back. People have died for it to be a
Muslim. They would sac- I believe Tommy
Robinson, if they said to him,
"Sacrifice your left limb and he's going
to be a Muslim," I'm sure he would say,
"Okay, go ahead with it." silly figure.
And Douglas Leece, oh, weapons
contractor. Uh he was a protege of
Douglas Leece. He was a business partner
uh to Stan Pottinger at the time that
Stan Pottinger was, you know, heavily
involved in Iran-Contra. He was, you
know, and and he knew and he ran in the
same circle as Adnan as Adnan Khashoggi.
And he has a fake passport. So, and then
he emerges out of Iran-Contra and with
enormous amounts of, you know, wealth
and power and connections. So, like just
And then of course there's the Robert
Maxwell connection, Ari Ben Menashe, um
who I don't know if you've had him on
your program, you should if you haven't.
Uh former Israeli uh former Israeli uh
intelligence official himself has said
that, you know, Epstein knew Maxwell. Um
whe- whether or not he did, that's that
that's an open question. Just tho- those
connections alone, and then for
Netanyahu to say that, "Well, okay, he
was very close to Ehud Barak, therefore
he had nothing, you know, to do with
Israeli intelligence," is is absurd.
Ehud Barak, you know, played a central
role uh however you want to define it in
Iran-Contra. He was an
Israeli intelligence official throughout
the 1980s. He was prime minister, he
becomes minister of defense. His, you
know, with another, you know, top
Israeli spy who was a protege of Ehud
Barak, Yoni Korem, you know, stayed for
like weeks at a time at Epstein's
apartment in Manhattan. So, I think the
public hears all of this information and
is like, "Okay, I I kind of think we get
it."
>> Yes, I think we get it that he is owned
by Mossad Epstein. I mean, so much so
that, for example, I'll show you guys
one image. One of the first images that
in a magazine uh prof in a magazine
profile, uh Donald Trump referred to
Epstein as a a terrific guy, "Likes
women as much as I do, many of them on
the younger side."
Okay, so I'm sure there's no really any
bells. Okay, and then we had
Rene uh Rene Alexander Acosta is an
American attorney and a politician. He
said, "Epstein belongs to the
intelligence. Leave him alone. Leave him
Leave the guy alone." And you're going
to hear You're going to hear from
Dershowitz's mouth what I just said
here. Okay, let's go straight into now
Bassem Youssef absolutely annihilating,
decimating, uh dissecting,
intellectually destroying Dershowitz. I
mean, look at the guy's face. Look at
Dershowitz's face.
Satanic. Satanic defending pedophiles.
One of the biggest pedophile maybe that
ever lived. If he had been a spy before
he pleaded guilty, the first person he
would have told that was me. I was
trying to get him the best possible
deal. And I asked him over and over
again, "What can you tell me that will
get you a better deal? Do you have
anything
>> Let's imagine this. Hey, uh you're a
pedophile. Yes, I am. I want to get you
the best deal, mate. You know, you know,
you go buy something, you know. He's
like, "Hey, man, look, I'm looking for a
nice 65-in TV. You got Listen, mate,
I've got you the best deal. I'm going to
get you the best deal.
My friend, can you imagine going
somewhere and saying, you know, going to
the place and saying, "Listen,
I'm a pedophile." And then the place
goes, "Listen, I'm going to get you the
best deal, mate." What the hell What the
hell you talking about? This is a
flipping individual who's pro-Zionist,
Zionist himself, okay, who's saying,
"I'm It's basically saying, 'I'm trying
to get him the best deal.'" Can you
imagine a Muslim lawyer who has a Muslim
client, okay, whatever you want to call
him, and he goes, "Listen, I'm going to
get you the best deal. You What What do
You What have you done? Paedophile, you
have raped and done what to satanic
things to little girls and boys? No
problem, mate. Cuz you're a Muslim, I'm
going to get you the best deal. That's
Sharia deal, mate. We're going to get
you the Sharia offer. Now, if Trump knew
if anything on Clinton, if you have
anything about intelligence, he would
have told me. Instead, in 1999 1998, I
was in Israel doing research for a book
and he called me from Paris saying, "I
want to come to Israel. I've never met
any Israelis. I don't know anybody
there. Could you arrange a lunch for me
with Israel's five smartest people?" And
so I did. I got the justice of the
Supreme Court, the attorney general, uh
you know, interesting people that I
thought he would meet. And uh we had
lunch and then he and I took a walk in
the shuk and I I bought him a t-shirt
which said, "I'm a member of the IDF."
Kind of uh
Yeah, I mean there is nothing pointing
out to that he was an Israeli. I said he
was Mossad. No, no, no, he was by the
Russians. I mean he comes up. He's He
introduces him to top five officials in
Israel. Yes? Can you imagine he's
saying, "Oh, do you know Trump? Do you
have anything on Trump?" or something
like that. It's like imagine a Muslim
say, "Hey, do you have anything on
Mohammed bin Salman and this guy and
this Muslim ruler, etc." You know, cuz
if you do, I will talk to him and get
you out of this mess. Can you imagine a
Muslim doing this? And this is how Allah
is humiliating because they try to
insult the Prophet Muhammad with false
lies of calling him a paedophile, I
would have been laughing, which is so
far from. He married a adult, Aisha.
Yes, okay, back then, which is the
equivalent of a 16 17 18-year-old today,
yeah? Okay.
And because this is the reason why Allah
is humiliating you guys because you guys
are the main culprit. Every accusation
is a confession. Let's carry on,
inshallah. Look again at It gets crazy,
guys. Just watch it. Let's watch the
give, okay? Don't watch Piers Morgan. I
will do this for you guys. Don't give
him the views. Okay, give it to Muslim
um channels like us. I've got it for you
guys, yeah? And I'll get the juicy bits.
khaki t-shirt and he loved it. He wore
it. Um
you know, there's no possibility that he
was working for intelligence at the time
I was representing him. Now we have a
chronological issue. We meet Sayed
Mubarak, uh but that's later. Did he Did
Mossad hire him after he was convicted?
Well, maybe. Your previous guest talked
about planes involving Victoria's
Secret. Well, Wexner didn't buy Victoria
Secret until well after the early time.
So, Hey, yeah, you know, can you
imagine? It gets better. Mossad didn't
argue Let's go argue with him. Mossad
was not working with him before. Mossad
starts working with him when he was a
convicted pedophile. Before they would
ask him, "Are you pedophile?" "Nah."
"Okay, once you get the pedophile
title, we want to work with you now cuz
this is someone we can work with." Makes
perfect sense. Defend You're defending
Mossad.
One has to look at the dates. One has to
look at the chronology. You know, I hate
to pour water on a fascinating
conspiracy theory. It's so much fun to
talk about, but from what I know, I just
don't see any evidence that that he ever
worked for the Mossad. And if he did,
why wouldn't he have told me? I actually
was a lawyer. I represented the Mossad.
Exactly. You know, Dershowitz with his
dad. He saved his life. Why would
Epstein, out of everybody, go and tell
Dershowitz and open up and cry and say,
"Listen, I work for the Mossad." Let me
think. Maybe cuz, you know, you yourself
got connections to Mossad as well. You
know, deep down he was working for
Mossad. What's he going to open up to
you for, my friend? You guys are in the
same field. You Do you think we're
stupid? Do you think we're stupid boy
yesterday, my friend? What do you think
this is here? The whole world's waking
up, my friend. Those days are over. Back
in the '90s, when three Mossad agents
were caught in Cyprus, and Cyprus
thought they were working for Turkey. In
fact, they weren't. And I helped to get
them out. I have a very good
relationship with the current head of
the Mossad, the former head of the
Mossad. Obviously, I've asked them that
question. And there's no evidence of it.
I mean, here Piers Morgan comes and he I
mean, I'm not going to lie. I don't
really like this guy with with the whole
Palestine thing, but he asks a question
that knocks him out. Let me ask you. You
know, if I was to ask you about all the
despicable crimes that Epstein was
committing, right? You would say, cuz I
think you said it publicly, you didn't
know about any of that, right? So, could
it be that Jeffrey Epstein just had a
completely [clears throat] different
life that he just did not tell you
about? And that included despicable
human sex trafficking. And just look at
Bob Esmond's face. He's just like it's
it's it's He's laughing. Like the guy is
it comes to a point where it's just it's
it's his comedy. It's hilarious. Like,
what Israel comes up with is just
comedy. Look at his face. But let's
carry on. And he may also have included
being a spy. I mean, clearly, if he
wasn't telling you about all the sex
trafficking, which was a huge amount of
his of his life, um then, you know, why
is it surprising if he kept the rest of
it from you? Well, well, that's that's
that's a good point. That's a good
point. But they're all on it together.
He's introduced [clears throat] him to
Mossad agents. Yes, top five officials,
etc. Yeah, and he's got no connections.
Yes, that's what I'm saying. No
connection to Mossad. Epstein has no
connection to Mossad. He's introduced
him to five officials.
Nothing.
Well, it's very surprising because
telling me about his sex life didn't
help him. Telling me that he worked for
the Mossad would have given him a get
get out of jail free card. Remember? Did
you just hear that? Did you Did you guys
Did What What What What What What What
What What What What What Did you guys
just hear that?
If Epstein, if he told him about his sex
the pedophile ring he has, it would have
not helped him.
But if he just told us that he works for
Mossad, apparently he doesn't know.
That would have helped him. Guys, just
just let's absorb and let's let the
nutritions and the nutrients
absorb them. Let the body absorb the
nutritions and nutritions here. So, if
he said, "I work for Mossad," he's just
admitted That's what Allah
says, "On the day of judgment, your
hands are going to testify."
Look how Allah has made this guy that
that stupid and dumb. The guy is
actually stupid and dumb. He's admitted,
yeah? If he said, "I work for the
Mossad," that would have been a get out
of jail free card.
Imagine the grooming gangs that have
nothing to do with Islam around These
people that the Sharia would have dealt
with them and hang them in Trafalgar
Square. Yes, we Muslims know how to deal
with these perpetrators. Oh, believe us.
No taxpayers' money. No hot food. No hot
water. Hot bed. None of that, my friend.
It's going to code
capital punishment and a cold burial.
Okay?
Can you imagine? And we go to these
people and say, "Oh,
Subhanallah. You are a a Muslim. If you
told us you work for this of Islamic
intelligence service, we could have got
you out free, mate. It doesn't matter if
you're a pedophile.
Jeffrey Epstein hated me before he died.
He wrote all kinds of letters to winning
on as to what a terrible lawyer I was.
He wouldn't pay me my fee. He fired me
because he thought I had gotten him a
terrible deal, that famous sweetheart
deal. He ended up 18 months in prison.
He was outraged. He didn't want to spend
a minute in prison. Okay, Epstein was
upset with Dershowitz.
WHY DID YOU NOT GET to me a better deal?
You got me only 18 months. Can you
imagine? You're a pedophile.
18 months? I didn't want to spend a day
in prison. And this Dershowitz
mentioning like it's something like a
pro point for him or something.
Epstein was upset with you because he
did not want to spend one day in prison
and he's upset that you got him 18
months.
I don't make this up.
Israeli Zionist pedophiles raping
American children
running back return with the
the right of return to Israel getting
away.
They are raping your children, bro. Your
kids. This is what you call a danger to
your children.
And it's just getting away with it, bro.
And he's upset. I could have gotten him
no jail time. If he had told me he
worked for the Mossad, for the CIA, he
was an intelligence source, it would
have been a slam dunk for me to go to
whoever I had to go to, even up to the
president of the United States, and I
would have gotten him a deal with no
time at all. Epstein was a selfish SOB.
He would do anything to avoid prison
time. Why wouldn't he have told me that
he worked for the Mossad if he worked
for the Mossad? So, yeah, of course he's
not going to tell me when I knew him as
an academic acquaintance, he's not going
to tell me he's having sex with young
children. He hid that from everybody. He
did have a separate life, a completely
separate life. But once I was his
lawyer, it was in his interest to tell
me things that would benefit him. And I
can't imagine anything benefiting him
more than having worked for an
intelligence agency. But I pressed him
on Some people might But this is this is
this is this this is unbelievable. He
has connections to Trump.
A lawyer, he has connections to Trump.
He goes to Trump, "Listen, you know, you
know those files, you know,
can we get him out?" Sure, no problem.
Yes, we've raped my done so many other
things, crazy satanic stuff to little
girls, but no, it's no problem. He knows
He knows some stuff about me. No, I'm
going to get him out. This is the
justice system of the Western world.
This is the human rights that they talk
about. You bloody hypocrites. You bloody
hypocrites. I'll come to Bassem in a
moment, but some people will be
listening to this guy and hang on a
second. You mean if he said he was
working with the Mossad or CIA, then he
would get off being a pedophile? Bingo.
Ding. Hello guys, the Western world.
Have you woken up yet? Hello. Have you
guys woken up yet? Hello. No? Okay. In
other words, you can commit crimes
against
children and you would you would simply
not go to prison for it.
That's right. Let's be clear. He was
charged with two counts. One a 17-year
and 10-month-old woman who he paid for a
prostitution, the other a woman in her
20s who was a prostitute who he paid.
Those are the only two things he pleaded
guilty to, the only two things he's ever
been convicted. He was never convicted
of pedophilia, he was never convicted of
trafficking, none of that. He may have
done all of those things, but when I was
representing him, all he was being
charged with was these two counts of
paying prostitutes. One who was 17 years
old and 10 months. I could have gotten
him no jail time for that if he had been
a member of the Mossad. Any good lawyer
could have parlayed his membership and
his contribution to intelligence into a
deal. Or for example, if he had anything
on Donald Trump or anything on Bill
Clinton, of course any prosecutor would
exchange this nobody who nobody had ever
heard of at the time getting free from
prison for my God, the president, former
president, future president. No, the
best evidence is that he never ever
tried to tell me anything strategically
consistent, not morally. If you know
something, we'll get you out. In Islam,
it doesn't matter who you know, what you
know, how you know.
The capital punishment is a capital
punishment even if it's the ruler.
Subhanallah. Look at that. And brother
Bassem there, I don't know how he stayed
silent, bro. That's That's That's That's
a patience, bro. The patience,
subhanallah. Look at this. Yes? And
guess what? They told him there was
multiple people that came. And guess
what? Because he's a solicitor and he
knows how he can get him out of that
mess. Dismiss. God knows what they did
that he was only charged with two
account two accounts, okay? Money,
bribery, God knows what was involved.
And now he's made him out to be some
innocent guy who just two counts of a
17-year-old 17-year-old 10-month-old
girl and a 12-year-old for prostitution.
Unbelievable. Let's go to Bob Bassam
too.
And I like this this scum.
Okay, Bassam Yousef, you've been waiting
patiently. Welcome back to Uncensored.
What is your response to Alan
Dershowitz?
Well, I I I think that what Mr. Alan
Dershowitz just said is the best
recruitment video for Mossad. Basically,
they're saying telling people if you're
Mossad, you can get away with anything.
The same thing that what happened with
Tom Alexandrovich, the cybersecurity guy
from Netanyahu's government who was
arrested in Nevada for trying to lure a
minor in an FBI sting operation and he
got off the hook. He traveled didn't
even have to attend his trial. He did
Zoom from Israel. And like Ori Solomon,
just a couple of days ago, there was a
biolab in Nevada that nobody is actually
talking about. Uh actually, as a matter
of fact, the mainstream media, they
reported it, but they never mentioned
his nationality as an Israeli who was
running a biolab in Nevada that includes
deadly viruses. If that was a Muslim, it
would be like all over the news. Hmm,
interesting. Can you imagine that? Can
you imagine Can you imagine that?
Subhanallah. A Israeli official going to
commit pedophilia, gets caught, and can
go right away and goes to Israel and
have like a nice casual little, you
know, on Zoom join
Just imagine, bro, Muslims were behind
this mess. Can you imagine Muslim
government officials, spies, you name
it, all involved raping children.
Pedophilia.
There'll be global uproar.
It says "Dinus".
Dinus can rape and be pedophiles.
That's fine. So, basically, Mr.
Dershowitz is telling us if you're
Mossad, you have like a an out of jail
card. And you know what? Maybe he's
right.
I actually watched you That's true. Mr.
Alan Dershowitz, I did not interrupt you
a single second when you talked. So,
like after you're done with your
gaslighting, please let me finish. Um
first of all, I think like I'm now kind
of leaning towards believing mainstream
media, especially CBS and CNN under very
wise and Larry Ellison. I mean the
evidence is there that he's actually a
Russian asset. His girlfriend Ghislaine
Maxwell Look, look, he he's a Russian
asset. Okay, he's a Russian asset.
Brother Bassam, prove us otherwise.
Epstein was a Russian asset. Do you have
evidence that he was not? He was the
daughter of a Mossad super spy. He was
represented by you, Mr. Dershowitz,
Israel's favorite lawyer. You're also a
lawyer to the Mossad, which of course
everything you tell us will be true. He
would Barack Hussein at please please
the whole time. He fled to Israel. He
was charged with sex crimes and he was
pictured wearing an IDF
charity. He was funded by pro-Israel
fanatics. He worked for the Rothschild.
He donated to pro-Israel student groups.
He was responsible for the Wexner Group
to pro-Israel
He supported Israel's settlement
projects. His friends are all Zionists.
He referred to us as He was
involved in Israeli diplomacy effort. He
brokered security deals with Israel and
even a former Israeli intelligence
officer, you know, Ari Ben Menashe, like
Mr. Ryan Grim said, he said he ran a
honey pot for Israel. So yes, of course,
he was definitely a Russian spy. Yes, he
was. There you go. There you go. He was
a Russian spy. Okay, you heard all the
evidences. He was a Russian spy. Yes,
definitely he was a Russian spy. Nothing
Nothing to do with the Israeli Mossad.
>> [laughter]
>> At all.
Makes sense. You know what? I'm actually
I'm by the way Mr. You're a good You're
a good
>> [laughter]
>> You're a comedian. This is very funny.
I'm a huge huge huge fan of yours
because I have known you since the
2000s. I mean actually one of the very
few lawyers who are actually known in
the Middle East. It's like watching a
real life courtroom drama lawyer.
There's even t-shirts with your face on
it and you and I've followed you for a
while and that's why I'm here today.
When they told me Mr. Dershowitz is
here, it's like I have to be here just
for the gaslighting because the level of
gaslighting is new. For more than 2 and
1/2 years Mr. Dershowitz and his client
Israel have gaslighted us in front of
our eyes for 2 and 1/2 years with all of
the destructions and the killing that
we've seen in Gaza, but they according
to them it's not a genocide, it's
self-defense. He told us that every day
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. that the
international Just I did not interrupt
you, sir. That the International Court
of Justice is a
And why is it that the United Nations
are anti-Semitic? Now Mr. Dershowitz,
please I did not interrupt you. Don't
interrupt me. I know that you're a
lawyer and you do that. Objection, your
honor. Don't interrupt me. Now, the
Epstein files are public. People can
read them. People can see the horrible
stuff that you again are guys Can you
imagine? Not a genocide.
It is not a genocide.
lighting us. In your own words, you said
that he's not a pedophile because he
liked 15 and 16 years old, but not 11
and 12 years old. No, I said 17 and 10
years old. Get it right.
Not 16, she was 17. Even if she was 14,
15, it doesn't matter.
He's an Israeli Mossad Zionist agent.
Who cares how old she is, bro? Even if
she's flipping 10, it it doesn't matter.
Is Is Is Is Is Israeli scum, it's no
problem. I'll get the age right. Get the
age right there, bro. You got it wrong.
People 17 and 10 years
>> read the ages of the kids in the emails.
They can read about the peeds and the
ice cream and the heat stroke. And you
can see the connection with Israel. And
yet, here you are again, gaslighting us.
This is your playbook, attacking the
victims. It's called Palestinians Hamas.
And the victims the victims liars,
prostitutes, drama students, and all
What do you say, Hamas are not
terrorists? You have a history of You
just imagine, guys, a Muslim lawyer,
like I said before, defending
Muslim pedophiles.
Yes, just imagine. And
and that can never be the case because
Islam has nothing to do with this. Islam
outright condemns this. Okay?
We don't have this thing. We don't have
this in our scriptures. I'm so sorry, we
don't have Talmud. Yes? That if you rape
a goyum girl, a non-Jew girl, that is
fine. It's no problem. There's no
problem at all.
Where in our Islamic Islamic scripture
do we have that? Yes? Tommy Robinson,
yes? GoFundMe, my friend. You're going
to talk about that. You do it back. Of
course not. You say Hamas are not
terrorists? to dig through teenage girls
at MySpace pages looking for marijuana
as well. Lawyers, you called a
16-year-old girl a thief in the Daily
Mail. You got Epstein 13 months in
county jail with work release for
abusing 34 victims, where he should have
got life in prison.
>> That's not actually what you said.
That's as far as I remember. You just
lied.
I CHALLENGE HIM TO DEFEND I challenge
you to defend your statement that we
presented at 18 months. YOU'RE JUST
LYING.
YOU'RE JUST LYING. And got him the deal
of the century. Two women accused you
under oath. You settled for nearly a
million dollars. Innocent men don't pay.
I will not pay a penny. You're a liar.
You're defaming. I I love how he's uh
panicking. Look look look how he's
panicking. You liar. You liar.
You are now going to You are now going
to have to be sued. You are now going to
be sued for saying I paid a million
dollars. You're going to be sued. And I
I would
Piers, I would not recommend you putting
him when he says that I paid a million
dollars. I didn't pay a million dollars.
That's what he said. That's what he
said. THAT'S WHAT HE OH BOY. OH BOY. Oh
boy. Brothers and sisters, I dare I
challenge any of the far right, any of
you scumbags, the enemies of Islam
to come and talk to me about pedophilia,
bro. You guys are the forefront runners
of pedophilia, from Jimmy Savile to
Epstein, okay, to all of these people,
subhanallah, who are connected. You guys
are the culprits. With all due respect,
it is you. Majority of the culprits is
always what? 90% what? Middle-aged white
men. I'm not saying every single one.
I'm saying you guys are This is your
problem. You guys are sickos, okay? And
once again, I'm not saying every white
person. But if you're going to come down
this route of pedophilia, it's either
the church, it's either Zionists
involved, or it is white middle-aged
men. This has nothing to do with us.
Yes, satanic rituals and raping little
innocent girls or boys. This is a
Western problem. This is not a Muslim
problem. What I'm going to say is that
inshallah brother Yusuf may Allah
uh bless him and uh allow him to
continue his work. And I'm in on this
let's play game show where we have a
card game. It'll be on the T, inshallah.
If anyone can get me in contact with him
to have him on the show, it will be
absolutely a pleasure. Till next time,
brothers and sisters. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullah wabarakatuh.